By surgeons, cancer mutation report for my colorectal tumor biopsy showed I had a K-ROS mutation.
So K-ROS genes do a number of different things, but they also function as tumor suppressor genes.
So also the surgical pathology exam showed the cancer to be an adenocarcinoma.
This is the carcinoma that is categorized by low levels of catalyst enzymes.
I ran across several papers for K-ROS gene variants and cancers with low catalysts.
Our good candidates for IV vitamin C. I said last week that I wasn't sure on that, but you showed
these reports of the study. So it's very interesting. I love my patients. You guys do more study
anybody out there. So good news. I did say last week because it did get recorded that your
program is written for an adenocarcinoma because that's what came up in your testing.
So I did look up your practice room to look at that. So that's good.
So remember K-ROS mutations are one of the tumor suppressor genes. So there's numerous gene
families that function as tumor suppressor genes. And the gene families also have other
functions other than tumor suppression. So remember what a tumor suppressor gene does. So they are
genes in your body in the cells that if the cell starts to go through rapid replication because of
something. Remember once a cause of cancer, something that gets inside the cell can be a toxin,
virus can be a bacteria can be a fungus can be anything that gets inside the cell that damages
the DNA. And then the cell goes in and starts to go into rapid replication and it replicates cells
that are also damaged in that DNA in a rap state of rapid replication. Well that happens. It should
kick on your tumor suppressor genes. Most common one that maybe you may have heard of is the P53G.
That's the most most research tumor suppressor gene. The first one that ever was discovered.
But also the BRCA gene. Everybody's heard that. So BRCA genes are tumor suppressor genes.
If you have a lot of defects in your tumor suppressor genes like your BRCA genes,
should you just get your organs removed? Well I think that's absolutely idiotic. But people have
done that. They have multiple double allele defects in their tumor suppressor genes. So they just
get their breasts removed and their ovaries removed. I just don't understand that logic.
A tumor suppressor gene doesn't cause cancer. A tumor suppressor gene though if you have
defects on that gene, it cannot kick in so that it won't stimulate a part of cancer death. So there's
two processes of program cell death, apoptosis. There's an intrinsic apoptosis that takes place
actually when a tumor suppressor gene kicks on. It kicks on an intrinsic apoptotic reaction.
So the cell goes into more feed and blebbing and destruction and basically recycling,
breakdown of that cell. Believe me, that happens every single day with people every day.
And if it didn't, we'd all be dead of cancer by the time we were five years old.
It's happening every single day. So just because you have a carousel mutation doesn't mean
you're going to have cancer. Just because you have brocco mutation does not mean you're going to have
cancer. But it does decrease that intrinsic. Now when we're working with the right, when we're working
with the immune system, we're trying to stimulate cancer death. We're all working on it.
The only way you can is you're working on the extrinsic apoptotic pathways.
So the extrinsic apoptotic pathways are from the outside of the cell. You're trying to get that cell
to go through cell death. So this reminds me, they're going to make a note. I'm going to send you
what did I already do that? And you're on the call. Did I send you the other things that will help
with k-ros mutations that are known? I think it was curcumin and some other things, but I won't do that
again. You made a note of it on the last call. Last week was it was so discombobulated last week. I
apologize. I computed it in work. And it cut out at the end. And then we had so much trouble with
those right machines. It was a rather stressful week. I had to take a whole bunch of
the data. But it's important for you guys, but I will send you that clip. Okay, thank you.